[Music]
congratulations on all the success of
the show did you guys have any clue when
you were a part of this that this was
going to be the hit that it is not in
the way that it happened no I think we
all liked it and we're like we think
it's good so no it's a bit of a
whirlwind when it came out but it's very
very exciting
they say that season two is gonna be
darker than season one
can you guys tease us a little bit and
tell us how so what is gonna happen I
think the little doll can assure me tell
more and you know we go a little wider
on what's what we're dealing with more
darkness eyes and organs we don't want
to get in trouble
you want them to just experience it
without knowing anything about the last
question how does it feel to begin the
Emmy wonderful it's it's awesome
especially Donna chose nominated for 18
518 so far it's amazing it's great to be
here now we have these guys here with us
yeah so back to you like fall and the
list of strange things sorry I had to
throw that out there Street definitely a
strange list of strange very weird
[Music]
you